sur public sénat
vous à tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat alors que la commission d'
enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité doit rendre son rapport le
25 juillet prochain
les sénateurs membres de cette
commission ont organisé hier une
dernière audition conjointe des
représentants de la cour des comptes
mais aussi des représentants d'edf
delahaye creux il s'agit de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
ainsi que des représentants de la
direction générale du ministère de
l'écologie et c'est cette audition que
je vous propose de suivre ce matin bonne
massenet tous
si vous le permettez monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues madame
monsieur nous allons démarrer cette
réunion et je veux refaire un petit
rappel sur cet ordre du jour un petit
peu particulier en ce sens que nous
avions sollicité le rapporteur et moi
même la cour des comptes pour demander
une actualisation de l'analyse que vous
aviez fait non pas sur le coût de
l'énergie et le prix d'électricité mais
que vous aviez fait dans votre rapport
2011 le président en fait c'est une
demande peu habituelle mais légal je
sais que votre président avait été à la
fois surpris mais a répondu tout à fait
avec sévérité je l'aurais déjà remercié
par écrit et je tiens à vous renouveler
mes remerciements d'avoir accepté de le
faire aussi de faire ce travail
d'actualisation qui est un travail quand
même assez complet dans un délai aussi
rapide alors la forme de l'audition
d'aujourd'hui est très particulière
puisque c'est ce complément de
banquettes de conclusion vous allez nous
les présenter et vous allez les
présenter en face des membres de la
commission des requêtes
les présenter également ils eurent eu
entre leurs mains ça leur permet de
réagir
à la commission de régulation de la
présenter à la direction de l'énergie et
de les présenter à et des airs de
manière à ce que chacun nous apporte
également ses réactions
c'est une méthode de travail que emploi
de temps en temps la commission des
finances is you c'est là et c'est une
méthode pour moi un peu nouvelle mais
très très intéressante
donc je vous donne la parole monsieur
gilles pierre lévy et vous michel palapa
lardeau je crois que vous vous êtes
répartis cette présentation
monsieur le président vous appuyez sur
le bouton parfait bien monsieur le
président et rapporteur général
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs donc effectivement vous avez
bien voulu demander à la cour de
procéder dans des conditions
effectivement qui sont très rarement
usité utiliser l'article 132 4 du code
des juridictions financières
un travail sur la mise à jour du train
de l'insertion rapport public annuel
qu'elle avait fait en début 2011 sur la
cspe
vous nous avez demandé de faire ça dans
un délai qui effectivement beaucoup plus
court que ce que nous faisons d'habitude
ce qui prouve quoi que on y arriver
grâce notamment au travail de michèle
pappalardo grâce également à la
coopération
de la creuse de l'année jacques d'edf
qui ont accepté également de contredire
sur ce sujet dans des délais
anormalement bref par rapport au réel
qui sont les nôtres et qui ont
effectivement donc eu l'occasion déjà de
réagir sur ces éléments dont ils vous
diront mieux que moi ce qu'ils peuvent
en penser
alors ce que vous aviez demandé c'était
donc d'actualiser les analyses et
d'effectuer le suivi des recommandations
qui avaient été faites par la cour
en ce qui concerne la contribution au
service public de l'électricité
alors si vous permettez si on part des
basiques
d'abord je m'en excuse pour ce qu'ils
sont des spécialistes de ces sujets dont
la cspc quoi c'est un succès hors de
prix du kilowattheure qui est payé par
le consommateur d'électricité et qui
vise à compenser trois types de charges
qui sont imposées aux producteurs
d'électricité c'est à dire d'abord avec
des f
les surcoûts dus à l'obligation d'achat
de l'électricité issue de la
cogénération et les énergies
renouvelables
sur l'ensemble du territoire les
surcoûts de production dues à la
péréquation tarifaire dans les zones non
interconnectées autrement dit pour
l'essentiel les îles et le coût des
dispositifs sociaux en faveur des
personnes en situation de précarité
donc ce que la cour a examiné ces trois
points d'abord elle a regardé ce qu'elle
avait dit en janvier 2011
deuxièmement elle à regarder l'évolution
des règles concernant la cspe
depuis cette insertion sert depuis
janvier 2011
et puis troisièmement elle a essayé d'
examiner les prévisions qui étaient
faites en matière d'évolution de la csp
tant en termes de recettes qu'en termes
de dépenses d'ici 2020 et pourquoi 2022
par c'est la date qui prises par les uns
et les autres et sont les perspectives
en matière de qui était retenue en
matière de programmation énergique
je me permets de rappeler d'abord les
recommandations qu'avait formulée à cour
dans son rapport de 2011 janvier 2011
donc qu'elle partait d'un constat qui
était le fait que le taux de la cspe
n'avait pas bougé depuis 2004 à 4,5
le mégawattheure qui ne permettait pas
de couvrir les surcoûts tu imposé aux
producteurs d'électricité ce qui
conduisait à un déficit cumulé pour edf
de l'ordre de 2,8 milliards d'euros
donc qui pesé sur le fond de roulement
alors la loi de finances initiale pour
2011 n'ont publié juste avant permettait
de relever significativement le taux de
la cspe la tour le constater elle
formulé quatre recommandations
la première était de mieux maîtriser les
facteurs de croissance des charges de
service public de l'électricité et au
premier rang d'entre elles l'obligation
d'achat à des tarifs très attractifs
fonctionnant entre guillemets à guichet
ouvert des énergies renouvelables
notamment la filière photovoltaïque
deuxièmement elle s'interrogeait sur
l'opportunité de continuer à soutenir
des filières qui n'était pas jugé
prioritaire dans la stratégie d'énergie
gouvernemental c'est à dire la
cogénération troisièmement elle suggéré
de remettre à plat le dispositif
d'ensemble afin de rendre le
fonctionnement plus lisible et le
clarifier le statut fiscal chat la cour
considérait en particulier que la cspe
que le conseil d'état avait qualifié
d'imposition est nommé en 2006 est en
fait effectivement un quasi impôt dont
le taux et les conditions de prélèvement
devrait faire l'objet d'une autorisation
périodique et d'un contrôle du parlement
et enfin le poser la question de
réexaminer le financement du soutien au
développement des énergies renouvelables
et des autres charges du service public
par le consommateur d'énergie en général
et pas seulement d'électricité alors ça
c'était les quatre recommandations que
formulé la cour dans son rapport de
janvier 2011
alors c'est mon deuxième point qu'est ce
qui s'est passé depuis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis à la
fois en matière de fixation des recettes
c'est-à-dire du taux de la contribution
supporté par les consommateurs
d'électricité et deuxièmement de calcul
des dépenses autrement dit des charges à
couvrir par cette contribution
alors pour ce qui concerne les recettes
tout d'abord le 6 juin vous montrent
leur évolution
les modifications législatives ont
permis l'augmentation de cette
contribution supporté par le
consommateur en laissant à la commission
de régulation de l'énergie
le soin de proposer un taux sur une base
objective de couverture des charges et
en prévoyant qu'en l'absence de décision
du ministre cette proposition
s'appliquerait entre guillemets par
délégation du dégustateur merlas en
limitant les augmentations possibles un
plafond de 3 euros par mégawatt heure et
par an en pratique quand on regarde les
chiffres on voit que la cspe est passé
de 4,5 euros par mégawattheure à 10 12
2009 pendant 13,7
ajout d'une pizza 10,5 à partir du 1er
juillet de cette année soit une hausse
de 133% en 18 mois
après une stagnation pendant six ans
alors compte tenu du plafonnement des os
et la croissance très rapide des
réponses des dépenses il faudra sans
doute on reviendra dessus attendre 2017
pour que le déficit cumulé par viel soit
résorbée je pense que les financier
d'edf en parlerons mieux que moi juste
un point à titre indicatif il est
intéressant de noter que le chiffre de
10 à 12,5 euros par mégawattheure donc
de juillet 2012 peut se comparer à un
chiffre de 35 9 euros par mégawattheure
est supportée par les ménages allemands
dans un but équivalent soit trois fois
et demi alors ça c'était ce qui s'est
passé en ce qui concerne les recettes le
taux de la contribution
quid des dépenses à couvrir par cette
contribution
je dirais il ya eu cinq principaux
points à relever
la principale mesure qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre a conduit à limiter le
tarif d'achat d'électricité
photovoltaïque et deux façons d'une part
en ne l'appliquant plus à guichet ouvert
aux installations qui dépasse 100
kilowatts
et de l'autre en révisant à la baisse
des tarifs d'achat pour les
installations de puissance inférieure
alors ceci dit les engagements qui
avaient été pris antérieurement en
faveur de l'installation qu'il n'est pas
encore en service ont été respectées et
donc en pratique se traduisent par un
accroissement des dépenses au fur et à
mesure de l'entrée en service de ces
installations
alors pour ce qu'est la cogénération les
henry dépit des réserves de la cour
constate que les textes n'ont pas été
modifiées cela dit dans la mesure où ils
restreignait le bénéfice de l'obligation
d'achat aux nouvelles installations de
puissance inférieure ou égale à 12
mégawatts heure aux installations
anciennes ayant fait l'objet d'une
rénovation significative l'arrivée à
terme d'une grande part des contrats
d'achat devrait se traduire par une
division de l'ordre de 3 entre 2010 et
2014 de la charge
troisièmement ce qui concerne les tarifs
sociaux ils sont à la hausse du fait
d'un meilleur niveau de prestations
couvertes et de l'automaticité du
versement du tarif de première nécessité
décision de l'ue décret du 6 mars 2012
en volume ces dépenses restent du second
ordre par rapport aux autres
quatrième point que rappelle ce
transparence slide la commission de
régulation de l'énergie a mis en place
une nouvelle méthode de calcul du coût
évité pour les obligations d'achat qui a
abouti en fait à stabiliser à réduire
fortement la volatilité dans la mesure
où on a plus que rapprocher le coût
prévu et le coup sur la base duquel
était calculée à cspe
c'est le point d de ce transparent enfin
point important sans modifier le tarif
d'achat mais en appliquant la méthode
des appels d'offres qui permet en fait
de s'en éloigner
2011 a été marqué par le lancement d'un
appel à projets pour 3000 mégawatts
d'éolien en mer un peu moins de 2030 été
retenu pour un prix d'achat très
supérieurs aux tarifs antérieurs
c'est-à-dire de 20 centimes d'euro le
kilowattheure contre 13 centimes d'euro
antérieurement qui n'avait de fait pas
permis jusqu'à ce jour de développer
forme de production d'électricité alors
là j'ai évoqué les points qu'ils avaient
bougé à l'exception de la cogénération
dans les textes en tout cas deux
recommandations de la cour n'ont pas été
suivies d'effet
la première portait sur le statut de la
cspe la cour y voyait un quasi-impôt ce
statut n'a pas bougé et deuxièmement les
charges financé par la cspe continue
peser sur le seul consommateur
d'électricité et il ne semble pas y
avoir eu de réflexion spécifique visant
à élargir la halle a déjà comparé à mai
mois cette contribution à d'autres
énergies
on a un transparent
je pense que les représentants des eft
d'edf pourront mieux commenté que nous
éventuellement l'impact sur edf de ce
qui s'est passé
on arrive à les charges à couvrir qui
était en 2010 de 2,6 milliards d'euros
on arrive aujourd'hui à des évolutions
qui se traduisent notamment par une
augmentation forte du coût lié à
l'esprit c'est photovoltaïque pour 2010
qui continuent d'augmenter plus lente
des couilles à la biomasse biogaz une
augmentation significative également de
ce qui concerne la bio la bagasse
charbon alors troisième point quelles
sont les prévisions d'évolution le d'ici
2020 gerin quand on regarde les trois
scénarios d'évolution des chats
d'anticipation donc celui d'edf sud à
cruijff lui le dgeq
on arrive à des prévisions de dépenses
pour 2020 est comprise entre 8 heures et
8 milliards d'euros et 18 9 contre 2 7
milliards en 2010 et une estimation
il sera peut être confirmées de 4,3
milliards en 2012
autrement dit une multiplication par un
peu plus de 3.5 entre 2010 et 2020 tu
pars un peu plus de deux entre 2012 et
le scénario le plus bas et celui d'edf
pour à l'expliquer fondamentalement
l'écart vient d'une estimation plus
basses du développement éolien en mer et
d'une anticipation d'une hausse plus
haut plus forte du prix du marché par
rapport auquel et calculs elle c'est
autrement dit d'un besoin de
différentiel plus faible quand on
regarde en décomposant les principales
sources d'augmentation de dépenses
la première c'est clairement les
énergies renouvelables dans la charge
passerait de l'ordre de 700 millions
d'euros à quelques 7 milliards et demi
soit une multiplication par plus de 10
en 10 ans ensuite on assisterait un
doublement des charges de péréquation au
profit des zones non interconnectées dom
tom qui passerait de l'ordre de 800
millions 802 millions 2010 à 1,9
milliard en 2020 selon les estimations
de la creuse troisièmement le troisième
source d'augmentation plus faible en
valeur absolue concernerait le
développement de l'énergie de
l'électricité produite à partir de la
bagasse dans les mêmes zones
les dom tom qui passerait de 168
millions d'euros à quelques 600 millions
d'euros en 2020 en ce qui concerne les
dispositifs à vocation sociale il
triplerait mais resterait encore d'un
impact beaucoup plus faible en valeur
absolue puisqu'il on passerait de
quelque 60 à 190 millions d'euros en dix
ans impact sur les comptes du producteur
globalement ils devraient le déficit
devrait passer des visites cumulées par
un pic entre 2014 et 2017 de l'ordre de
4 milliard d'euros et disparaître aux
alentours de 2017
si la politique suivie jusqu'à présent
en matière d'évolution des tarifs
étaient maintenues c'est à dire
augmentation tant que les charges sont
pas couvertes avec une limitation à 3
centimes d'euros par an le la
contribution demandée aux consommateurs
d'électricité devrait doubler
globalement passé de l'ordre à quelques
20 20 euros par mégawattheure en 2020
conclusion la situation d'edf
on a dit un mot je crois conclusion
quelques pistes de réflexion si l'on
souhaitait limiter l'impact sur les
consommateurs d'électricité de ces
évolutions la première reste toujours à
l'élargissement du financement des
énergies renouvelables à l'ensemble des
énergies faire peser cette charge non
seulement sur la consommation
d'électricité mais sur d'autres sources
d'énergie à travers la fiscalité par
exemple la deuxième pourrait peut-être
d'utiliser d'autres sources de recettes
ayant pour origine la production
d'électricité par exemple la vente aux
enchères des quotas d'émission sachant
il est clair que si on les utilise
à cet effet on ne disait pas autre chose
par exemple pour combler le déficit du
budget troisièmement à réexaminer les
règles d'exonération qui existe
actuellement
d'autres pistes de travail pourrait
également concerner la l'optimisation de
la production d'énergie renouvelable et
sans doute aussi amélioré vise à
améliorer la liquidité et la
transparence du marché l'électricité il
s'agit là de pistes de réflexion voilà
ce que nous avons écrit dans ce document
monsieur le président sur le rapporteur
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs je vous remercie de votre
attention je vous remercie monsieur une
synthèse a résumé de vos conclusions qui
sont assez pertinente
alors moi ce que je vous propose c'est
c'est un petit peu peut-être d'écouter
ceux qui sont interpellés si vous le
voulez bien
chacun à tour de rôle je sais pas qu'est
ce qui serait mieux je pense que ce
serait peut-être la direction de
l'énergie d'abord où le régulateur
d'abord de régulateur d'abord on met le
régulateur puis la direction d'énergie
puis et df alors sur la partie
diagnostic et autres wii allez-y
puis je viens aussi que vous écoutez sur
la partie de vos prévisions
dans l'étape 2012-2020 puisque là il y a
notamment une divergence et les
conclusions ne sont pas les mêmes entre
vous le régulateur entre la direction de
l'énergie est entré df
merci monsieur le président je vois tout
d'abord salué la qualité du travail de
la cour quand on connaît la complexité
de la cspe c'était vraiment un challenge
de réussir à rendre ce rapport
compréhensible je pense en tout cas et
je remercie mme pappallardo pour la
qualité des échanges avec la creux alors
je vais revenir tout de suite sur les
scénarios d'évolution j'aurais pu le
faire
je voudrais donc revenir tout de suite
sur les scénarios de scénarios
d'évolution la csp à 2020 alors je crois
qu'il est très important de comprendre
mais je crois que madame pappalardo la
très bien mentionné dans son rapport que
ce sont des exercices différents en
particulier la creux comme la dgeq
considère pour les nerfs que les
hypothèses les objectifs de la purée
programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements seront atteints en 2020
donc c'est une hypothèse dimensionnant
tu en particulier l'éolien offshore
on considère l'objectif c'est un
exercice théorique complètement
théorique donc de 6000 mégawatts en 2020
et par contre pour photovoltaïque on
considère que les objectifs seront un
peu dépassé alors ce sont c'est un
exercice théorique mais il me semble que
c'est un exercice qui donne un ordre de
grandeur de ce que coûteront en
particulier les énergies renouvelables
quant aux objectifs seront atteints
puisque il ya une volonté d atteindre
ils seront vraisemblablement pas atteint
en 2020 vraisemblablement après
mais néanmoins on peut penser que les
chiffres atteints dans ce cadre la part
en tout cas par la creux donne un ordre
de grandeur de ce que coûteront les
énergies renouvelables quant aux
objectifs seront atteints
donc ce qu'ils sont trois exercices
différents même si ces deux-là creux
rejoint davantage celui de la d'échec
puisque les hypothèses en tout cas sur
les objectifs de nerfs et sur les prix
de marché qui sont aussi dit mentionnant
sont les mêmes donc on se rejoint là
dessus ce qu'on peut constater
simplement c'est que aujourd'hui en
particulier pour les nerfs ça coûte déjà
assez cher mais surtout en 2020 ça va
coûter beaucoup beaucoup plus cher à
cause du coût élevé de ces énergies
justin un prix pour fixer un peu les
ordres de grandeur la production
d'énergies renouvelables qui sera
soutenue en 2020 d'un scénario de la
crue on estime que cela représentera 15%
de la production totale de france je 15%
en considérant les scénarios de
production basé établi par rte 15% de la
production mais le coût global des
énergies renouvelables pas le surcoût le
coût global de la facture dans la part
énergie de la facture dépassera 30 %
plus de deux fois ce que représentera ce
que représenteront les énergies
renouvelables dans la production
ces scénarios sont basées sur une
hypothèse y mentionnant que sont les
prix de marché je les dis la creuse à
considérer les primes
le prix de marché qui était à l'époque
de 54 euros par mégawattheure en mars
et puis a pris une évolution de 3 % par
an c'est-à-dire l'inflation +1 1% alors
en matière de prévisions je crois qu'on
façon je pense qu'on se trompe tous j'en
veux pour preuve que quand la creux
avait il ya quelques années alerté le
ministre sur les dérives qu'on pourrait
constater sur le coût des énergies
renouvelables mais nous avait été
rétorqué que toute façon le prix de
marché dans quelques années serait à 120
euros du mégawattheures est donc
finalement on ne verrait plus sur coup
des énergies renouvelables voilà
aujourd'hui on était à 54 euros en mars
on est à 60 de l'année dernière 54 en
mars 2012 49 euros aujourd'hui
voilà j'en tire aucune conclusion pour
l'avenir simplement ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que plus il ya d'énergies
renouvelables notamment en allemagne et
en france
plus toutes choses égales par ailleurs
toutes choses égales par ailleurs le
prix de marché baissent c'est à dire que
ce sont des énergies fatales
donc le dernier moyen appelé et bien par
définition il est moins cher et c'est
principalement ce qu'on constate un peu
aujourd'hui et voir on atteint même des
prix de marché négatif alors donc ces
scénarios ne sont pas comparables
ils disent juste qu'on va vers beaucoup
plus voilà est juste une petite
observation dans pages 65 du rapport il
est écrit que si l'on intègre sinon un
teg la bagasse charbon les scénarios de
eu d'effet de la crue sont parfaitement
comparables je maudirai peut-être un
tout petit peu la rédaction sur ce point
je pense qu'ils sont pas comparables du
tout même si de fait en intégrant la
bagasse charbon ce même périmètre
voilà alors pour ce qui concerne les
propositions de la cour la crau ne va
pas se prononcer ils se croient que
c'est pas son rôle sur le financement
des énergies renouvelables par d'autres
énergies néanmoins il faut bien avoir à
l'esprit que la csp ou sait pas que les
énergies renouvelables
donc si on fait financer les nerfs par
d'autres énergies et bien il faudra
faire financer la péréquation tarifaire
tête parce qu'il restera de la cspe et
puis le dispositions sociales peut-être
par autre chose mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas simple à
mettre en oeuvre
enfin il est fait mention dans les
conclusions du mécanisme qui a été mis
en place aux pays bas dans le but
notamment d'inciter les producteurs à
vendre leur production sur le marché les
productions intervenir avant de leur
production sur le marché au moment où
c'est plus intéressant pour le système
donc là où les prix de marché sont plus
élevés
or un peu dubitatif puisque les énergies
renouvelables en tout cas aujourd'hui
pour la plupart ne sont pas contrôlables
le photovoltaïque l'éolien
même la biomasse la biomasse il ya un
débouché chaleur l'industrie on va pas
lui dire ben non on va pas produire
maintenant parce que les prix de marché
sont pas assez élevés donc laissez les
énergies renouvelables en général ne
sont pas contrôlables
donc même si on met un dispositif qui
est basé sur le prix de marché et qui
donne une prime pour au prix de marché
il sera très difficile de contrôler la
production pour la vendre au meilleur
moment
et donc je ne suis pas sûr que même avec
ce dispositif le l'objectif qui serait
de produire à partir d'énergies
renouvelables au moment où c'est plus
intéressant pour système soit atteint et
qu'il soit d'ailleurs jamais atteint
enfin dernier point il est question dans
les monts conclusions des différentes
exonérations en cours et d'éventuelles
modifications de ces exonérations la
crau n'a évidemment pas de position à
prendre sur cette zone euro exonération
qui je vous le rappelle pour certaines
exonère notamment les sociétés
industrielles
hauteur donc de faim elle paye au
maximum 0 5% de la valeur ajoutée va
pour être tous les jours en contact pas
moi directement mais mes équipes avec
ces sociétés
voilà je pense que vous faut être
conscient de l'impact que ça va sur ses
sociétés industrielles en particulier
bien des côtés de merci merci pour cette
vos réactions sur les objectifs de vie
20 c'est vrai qu'on les atteindra
vraisemblablement pas en matière
d'éolien en matériaux photovoltaïques
je dis pas que l'on pulvérisé ram et on
sera loin au delà du grenelle de
l'environnement on sera loin au-delà
donc sur la partie production
on commence quand même à avoir des
petites idées de là au risque d'aller
enfin ça m'intéresse d'avoir les
réactions des uns et des autres là
dessus par contre sur les prix vous avez
raison le prix du marché on voit bien la
vitesse à laquelle évolue alors sur vous
vos conclusions là sur les noms sur les
autres suggestions du rapport de la cour
là vous êtes en audition officiel c'est
vrai que la régulateur n'a pas donné son
avis sur un certain nombre de choses
notamment le fait que la charge de la
cspe pourrait être supporté pas
simplement par le consommateur
d'électricité mais par d'autres
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile pour
vous c'est pas votre rôle mais moi je
pense que si nous menons comme vous le
suggérez une réflexion là dessus dans
l'avenir et le parlement aux six rameurs
à cette réflexion
je pense que dans je dirais des
instances de travail
vous avez tout à fait votre rôle et vous
pouvez vous pourrez parfaitement y
participer vous êtes un acteur qui
connaissait bien le sujet vous vouliez
acheter quelque chose d'aussi haut débit
non là on est sur la partie précisément
où le parlement porte une appréciation
de nature politique et la cour peut dire
voilà des pistes possibles
après ça qui doit apprécier que ce qui
va supporter la charge de consommateurs
particuliers industriels
j'ai beaucoup apprécié que vous alliez
assez loin dans vos suggestions vos
pistes de réflexion vous utilisez des
mots prudemment mais vous dites que ça
mérite qu'on y aille
oui pappalardo
merci oui c'est sûr effectivement des
pistes on n'a pas eu de de toute façon
le temps de les approfondir donc c'était
juste pour montrer ce qui aujourd'hui
est sur la table en dame de réflexion
qui nous paraissent intéressantes à
approfondir mes mais ça n'est pas plus
que ça et effectivement les pisans tous
les sens juste une toute petite
précision par rapport à ce que savait
dicte nos débuts sur les finalement le
les hypothèses qui sont prises en compte
dans les scénarios sur la réalisation en
volume alors donc comme on l'a dit il à
creux et la dgec font leurs calculs sur
l'hypothèse que la paix pays
complètement atteinte et donc
effectivement on a nos 6000 mégawatts
d'éolien comme vous le faisait remarquer
également sur le photovoltaïque qu'on va
faire plus que la paix pays c'est clair
mais c'est pris en compte dans les
scénarios et ils ont tous les deux
assuré d'être aussi fait une hypothèse
on va dépasser c'est une hypothèse
d'ailleurs qu'on va dépasser ce qui est
prévu dans la paix pays et par contre il
se cale sur les objectifs qui ont été
recalés en fait de la paix pays avec une
augmentation de 500 mégawatts par par an
à partir de résultats 2012 2013 par
forcément encore complètement clair donc
voilà la vision que vous avez à travers
les chefs de la creuse et la dgec
c'est la pp y aménager en matière de
photovoltaïque tenant compte déjà de
l'augmentation qui est plus que probable
on va passer la parole à l'échec mais
dans votre rapport vous avez réseau nous
dit bien que les contrats d'avant le
moratoire devront être respectées et je
suis frappé trucks et edf qui l'a fait
remarquer le taux de remplissage si je
puis dire
le taux de projets qui ont une suite est
très important on pensait qu'ils
allaient avoir plus de déchets plus de
projets qui allaient être abandonnés ce
qui n'est pas le cas alors la dg
monsieur le président messieurs les
sénateurs
merci merci nous donner la parole tout
d'abord je voudrais remercier la cour
des comptes pour le travail qui a été
fait comme la crosse salué la qualité de
ce travail est de là qu de la
coopération avec nous au cours de cette
de cette période dans un dans un délai
contraint la dgec rejoint là l'essentiel
des comptes des constats qui ont été
faits par là par la cour notamment sur
la tendance de fond qui est à
l'augmentation des charges de service
public d'électricité qui est liée non
seulement aux renouvelables mais aussi à
d'autres postes comme la péréquation
tarifaire qui n'est pas du tout
négligeable dans l'évolution d'ensemble
cela étant dit je voudrais faire
quelques remarques
d'abord sur les sur les scénarios et sur
les incertitudes qui sont liées à ces
scénarios
je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit ce
qu'a dit la creux précédemment scénario
repose sur un certain nombre
d'hypothèses forte alors il y a le
scénario des prix de l'électricité
il est vrai que la tendance est
aujourd'hui plutôt plutôt à la baisse
mais je crois qu'à l'horizon 2020 on
serait bien en peine de faire une
estimation fiable de l'évolution des
prix si on s'était posé la question
huit ans auparavant du niveau des prix
aujourd'hui on se serait trompé
comme le disait madame pévèle donc c'est
une hypothèse forte parce que si on
suppose par exemple que les prix de
l'électricité atteindront 90 euros en
2020 ça fait 2 milliards de moins sur
les charges de csp donc c'est ce n'est
vraiment pas c'était vraiment pas
anecdotique
alors il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
hypothèses fortes qui sont faites sur
l'atteinte des objectifs de la pp ça a
déjà été largement soulignée en même
temps ce sont pas des se sont pas des
des projections il réaliste celles qui
sont celles qui sont faites on sait pas
si elles seront atteintes en 2020 en
tiens ou en 2019 mais par contre ce sont
de bons ordre de grandeur et donc je
rejoins ce qui a dit la creuse sur le
fait que les montants qui sont cités là
sont à prendre comme des ordres de
grandeur mais ce sont vraisemblablement
des ordres de grandeurs fiable de
l'évolution des charges de service
public
autre remarque je voudrais souligner
mais ça a été très bien dit par la cour
des comptes de l'année de l'importance
des travaux qui ont été menés au cours
des dernières années pour maîtriser
assurer la pérennité du dispositif
maîtriser ses coûts engagées la
résorption de la dette en tout cas se
mettre dans une dans un système qui
permet d'engager la résorption de la
dette alors c'est non seulement le la
modification législative qui permet une
revalorisation plus automatique de la
contribution au service public de
l'électricité de façon à ce qu'elles
suivent l'évolution découvre dont ça a
bien été dit ils vont augmenter donc il
fallait mettre en place un système qui
permet de revaloriser automatiquement
cette cspe est le deuxième point
important c'est la maîtrise des dépenses
et là je reviendrai pas sur ce qui a été
dit sur le photovoltaïque qui est assez
emblématique de ce qui a été fait et sur
le développement le plus souvent
possible d'appels d'offres qui
permettent de maîtriser le
nombre et le volume de projets retenus
sur cette fois ci sur les
recommandations et les propositions de
la cour des comptes
je voudrais réagir sur deux sur deux sur
deux propositions
la première concerne l'évolution du
mécanisme d'obligation d'achat la dgec
elle accueille avec intérêt les
réflexions qui sont esquissées par par
là par certains acteurs et qui sont
reprises par la cour des comptes sur le
sur le sujet il ya d'autres pays
européens qui se pose en même temps le
même type de le même type de questions
et c'est un travail à c'est un travail à
poursuivre sur le financement
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet compliqué
la question de la du financement des du
développement des renouvelables par
d'autres énergies et une question
compliquée en particulier dans un
contexte où le prix des autres énergies
est également très élevé pour le pour le
consommateur et donc dans ce dans ce
contexte je voudrais faire deux
remarques pour aider à la réflexion
le premier point c'est que le doublement
dont on parle dont deux en matière de
cspe cela représente à peu près 10 euros
par mégawattheure 10 euros par
mégawattheure c'est de l'ordre de 7 ou 8
% de la facture actuelle d'un d'un d'un
ménage et la deuxième la deuxième
remarque que je voulais faire c'est que
il est a priori sein de notre point de
vue que les charges liées au
développement des nerfs d'un secteur
donné soit financée par ce secteur c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe pour le gaz
c'est ce qui se passe aussi pour les
biocarburants et cette internalisation
des dépenses est en quelque sorte une
vertueuse dans la logique de maîtrise de
l'évolution des coûts voilà monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs ce que
je voulais souligner puisque vous nous
donner la parole et d'écouté merci
merci beaucoup et je partage notamment
votre avis sur le fait que les dents les
pistes de le mérite de votre travail
c'est qu'en plus c'est un rapport
officiel de la cour des comptes donc ce
dont on parle un peu partout notamment
et pistes de réflexion sur
l'élargissement de l'assiette de ceux
qui supporte la charge de la cspe
le fait que sa figure dans un rapport de
la cour des comptes ça commence à
prendre du poids et ça va obliger les
uns les autres a rappelé alors qu'edf et
df vous voulez encore charger un peu
plus la cspe parce que non seulement
comme le rappelait mme se tenir là à
l'instant le rapport précise bien que ce
sont pas simplement c'est pas simplement
la cogénération pas simplement les
grandes énergies renouvelables dont on
parle mais ce sont les autres aussi un
le biogaz la biomasse la petite
hydraulique en allant vous vous trouvez
qu'il n'y en a pas assez dessus puisque
vous considérez notamment que les
charges que vous supportez notamment
pour l'obligation d'achat vous
considérez que ça a un coût et un coût
qui évolueront vous comprends très bien
1 quand il ya non pas quelques dizaines
de champs éoliens
mais quand il ya quelques centaines de
milliers de producteurs de
photovoltaïque
c'est un coup et vous considère aussi
qu'il ya un autre coup important c'est
le déficit dont vous assumez la
trésorerie donc si j'ai bien compris
vous voulez surcharger un peu plus la
csp mais ça sera allez-y à la fois sur
le diagnostic sur les prospectives 2020
et sur vos demandes bien merci monsieur
le président monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs tout d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier nous donner la possibilité de
nous exprimer sur ce rapport de la cour
des comptes sur la cspe cspe est un
sujet qui nous occupe et j'ai presque
envie de dire qui nous préoccupe pour
certains d'ailleurs des des remarques
vous venez de faire
c'est un mécanisme qui est déséquilibré
et c'est bien edf qui en subit les
conséquences
d'ailleurs à ce titre aujourd'hui
j'interviens en tant que directeur
financier du groupe et l'ensemble de mes
observations seront faites à ce titre de
directeur financier puisque le
déséquilibre est principalement d'ordre
financier premier des commentaires je
souhaiterais faire naturellement comme
l'ensemble des personnes qui se sont
exprimées c'est tout d'abord de
remarquer la qualité du rapport
l'exhaustivité ainsi que le diagnostic
précis et complet et partagé qui est
fait sur la situation de ce dispositif
ainsi que sur les propositions qui nous
trouvons très intéressantes sur
lesquelles je reviendrai dans un moment
alors ce rapport met en évidence deux
problèmes majeurs sur lesquels je
souhaiterais bien revenir à nouveau dans
cette dans ce cadre deux problématiques
financières qui pèsent sur le groupe edf
le premier de ces problèmes vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le président c'est le
déficit actuel difficile de compensation
vous avez bien montré les chiffres tout
à l'heure il est très élevé 3,8
milliards d'euros fin 2011 plus de 4
milliards d'euros en ce moment même et
même des f ne peut pas supporter un tel
déficit de façon durable
le second problème qui est tout aussi
important sur lequel je vais revenir en
détail et que vous êtes gagnant en
évidence malgré le fait que ça ne
représentent que quelques pour cent
d'augmentation de la facture que nous là
dgeq là exprimé c'est tout de même
l'évolution du poids de la cspe dans la
facture globale des consommateurs
et ça pour nous c'est un vrai sujet au
moment où edf doit investir et j'y
reviendrai dans la minute lorsque le
premier problème le déficit de
compensation et les charges financières
qu'il génère alors le rapport de la cour
des comptes constate que les charges de
service public ont augmenté rapidement
et que la contribution la cspe n'a pas
été relevé en conséquence ce problème de
déficit avait bien été perçus en 2010 et
des dispositions législatives ont été
prises
simplement comme vous l'avez bien
souligner tout à l'heure ces
dispositions n'ont pas suffi à répondre
à l'ampleur de la situation juste pour
redonner quelques chiffres mais tout
ceci dans le contexte le déficit donc
été financée par la trésorerie du groupe
edf était de 500 millions d'euros en
700 2008 et ensuite c'est plus un
milliard d'euros par an + 5 milliards
d'euros en 2010 + 1 milliard d'euros en
2011 une augmentation très sensible
encore en 2012 puisqu'il devrait
dépasser 4 5 milliards c'est d'autant de
trésorerie d'edf qui est ponctionnée ce
qui pose naturellement un problème pour
le groupe
alors pourquoi parce que edf a une
particularité c'est que nous sommes le
groupe d'électricité qui investit le
plus dans notre industrie en europe
deuxième particularité c'est que à la
différence de tous nos concurrents en
europe
notre programme d'investissement est à
la hausse je pense là naturellement et
principalement à la france la france qui
représente plus des deux tiers des
investissements du groupe edf
la france où nous investissons en 2011
plus de 7 milliards d'euros ce chiffre
pourrait dépasser 10 milliards d'euros
en 2015
et au moment où notre programme
d'investissement est à la hausse
nous devons nous financer sur les
marchés internationaux
alors je ne suis pas naturellement ici
pour commenter l'utilité des agences de
rating mais ils se trouvent les agences
de notation financières elle se trouve
que aujourd'hui nous avons la meilleure
notation financière de notre secteur il
est très important que nous le
conservions justement compte tenu notre
programme d'investissement et compte
tenu du fait que nous devons aller
chercher des investisseurs dans notre
dette
le plus largement possible ce déficit de
compensation représente plus de 10% de
notre dette et pèse donc autant sur
notre structure financière et sur notre
capacité à nous financer dans de bonnes
conditions
c'est le premier problème que je tiens à
souligner d'autant plus que le
corollaire de ces déficits c'est qu'ils
entraînent des coûts de financement des
coûts de portage très significatif pour
le groupe vous imaginez que 4 milliards
d'euros aux coûts de financement et au
coût du capital d'edf
ça représente un déficit d'intérêt
extrêmement significatif
d'ailleurs à ce titre il nous apparaît
que ce déficit qui n'avait pas été
imaginé à l'origine du dispositif
occasion donc une charge financière qui
dans ce principe dans leur principe
devrait être compensée par la cspe elle
même nous pensons que les modalités de
calcul des charges financières devrait
être aujourd'hui préciser dans la loi et
la réglementation et pourrait être
expressément intégrés dans la liste des
charges à compenser ceux ci pourraient
être faits à l'occasion de la prochaine
loi de finances rectificative il en va
d'ailleurs de même des coûts de gestion
toutes les obligations d'achat c'est le
président vous mentionnez tout à l'heure
le nombre de champs c'est autant de
contrats que nous devons gérer ce sont
des coûts de gestion de plus en plus
significative l'entreprise edf et nous
pensons aussi que comme l'esprit de la
loi c'est que des f soit compensée pour
la totalité des charges liées au service
public de l'électricité et bien à la
fois ce coût de portage et ce coût de
gestion devrait être bien inclus dans la
liste des charges à compenser j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que cette juste compensation
permettrait de d'effacer ses coûts donc
dans les comptes d'edf augmentant
d'autant le résultat avant impôts du
groupe et donc la charge d'impôts que
des f&a qui trait à l'état français est
aussi le dividende si l'actionnaire
souhaite augmenter le dividende versé
par edf
alimentant d'autant déficits budgétaires
auxquelles tout à l'heure monsieur lévy
vous faisait référence
voilà donc un premier problème lié au
déficit extrêmement significatif que
supportent edf
le deuxième problème tout aussi
important c'est le poids de cette taxe
dans la facture du consommateur parce
que même si
somme tout petit peu divergent sur les
scénarios dont je crois que le rapport
de la cour des comptes le montre très
bien montre bien toutes les hypothèses
qui sous tendent ces scénarios
il n'en reste pas moins que même si 100
9 ou 11 milliards d'euros à horizon 2020
la taxe devrait passer de 10 à plus de
20 à cet horizon même s'il ne s'agit que
quelques points d'augmentation de la
facture
c'est d'autant de moins d'augmentation
de la facture qui pourrait être consacré
à autre chose que l'augmentation de
cette taxe et notamment aux
investissements très significatif que
doit faire le groupe edf en france
je crois que c'est un élément
extrêmement important c'est que si des
possibilités d'augmentation de la
facture du client du consommateur en
france existe il est extrêmement
important que ces possibilités
d'augmentation soit principalement
consacré à l'augmentation des
investissements au financement de
l'augmentation des investissements d'edf
que ce soit dans le parc de production
ou même avant les conséquences les
conséquences de fukushima
nous avions prévu de doubler les
investissements dans la maintenance du
parc de production en france passant de
1,7 milliard d'euros en 2010 à 3 50 2015
avant même les conséquences de fukushima
par ailleurs nous augmentons très
significativement tous les ans les
investissements dans les réseaux + 10 %
en 2011 + 25 % d'ailleurs dans la
qualité des réseaux et donc si une
augmentation de la facture du
consommateur du client est possible nous
pensons qu'il est plus judicieux qu'elle
aille dans la composante du tarif
intégré de vente qui nous permet
d'investir plutôt que dans
l'augmentation de cette taxe
à ce titre d'ailleurs les pistes qui
sont ouvertes par la cour sur le
financement des décharges au futur
naturellement de paresse
extraordinairement pertinente qu'il
s'agisse de l'élargissement du
financement des énergies renouvelables
d'autres sources d'énergie ainsi que
l'utilisation d'autres sources de
recettes
il est tout petit peu paradoxal que le
producteur d'électricité le plus
décarbonés dans son industrie finance le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et on supporte en tout cas
quasi exclusivité le déséquilibre je
refais d'ailleurs le lien avec le
premier point c'est que si si df
disposer d'une rémunération donc d'une
de temps une compensation pour le coût
de portage de ses déficits
ainsi edf était totalement compensée
pour la totalité de ces coûts liés au
service public de l'électricité
notamment sur le déficit
nous pourrions à ce moment-là envisagée
sur le plan purement financier un
étalement du remboursement de ce déficit
sur beaucoup plus longue période que ce
qui est prévu vous les avez raison de le
souligner tout à l'heure d'ici au delà
de 2017
ce qui permettrait donc de dégager une
marge de manoeuvre dans l'augmentation
mécanique prévu de cette taxe et c'est
donc là où je fais le lien avec le
premier sujet tout est lié
si nous sommes compenser sur le coût de
portage le coût financier
nous pouvons envisager un étalement de
ceux de la perception de ce déficit
donc en conclusion j'espère ne pas avoir
été trop long mais oui
df partage totalement la conclusion la
cour des comptes sur la nécessité de
rechercher des moyens d'alléger le poids
de la cspe sur les factures
d'électricité
s'agissant de la couverture des charges
futures nous adhérons pleinement
recommandations de la cour qui suggèrent
un élargissement des pistes de
financement
un état lycée comme comme je viens de le
répéter un étalement du déficit
historique pourrait également être
envisagée ce sera une mesure
complémentaire mais dans l'immédiat
pardon d'insister je profite de cette
occasion pour le pour le faire c'est
bien le problème du financement du
déficit de compensation qui doit être
résolu il est nécessaire que ce principe
de compensation intégrale des charges
posées par la loi soit appliquée aux
charges financières aux coûts de gestion
ces charges doivent être expressément
intégrés de notre point de vue dans la
liste des charges à compenser à nouveau
gelé mentionné tout à l'heure les
aménagements de la loi de
l'argumentation pourrait être pris en ce
sens était la prochaine loi de finances
rectificative
je vous remercie à nouveau pour cette
opportunité et pour votre attention
pendant cet exposé merci bien monsieur
clip mal merci je suis pas surpris ni
choqué par votre demande deuxième sont
normales que notamment directeur
financier mais que vous êtes seriez que
vous ayez des demandes à faire en
matière financière compte tenu des coûts
que représente et des problèmes que
représente le fait que c'est vous qui
assure y est c'est vous qui est sur la
trésorerie
ces aspects c'est clair et net donc je
ne suis pas ça monsieur compass mais
merci aussi de votre contribution pas
simplement financière mais également sur
l'autre volet important du rapport à
monsieur le rapporteur savez trés bull à
la parole moi j'en ai quand même dire on
rend vraiment hommage au travail que
vous avez fait une de vos
recommandations qui m'a le plus plu et
ça ne vous surprendra pas c'est pas du
tout celle que vous faites dans ce
complément de travail je tiens vous le
dire
elle a aussi je rends hommage à seul
dans la recommandation que vous avez
faites dans votre bilan 2011
c'est celle où vous suggériez une remise
à plat de l'ensemble du système que vous
appeliez cette cspe un quasi impôt et
qu'il fallait qu'il y est un contrôle
notamment un contrôle plus régulier et
parlementaires sur l'évolution de cette
cspe
surtout quand on voit la tournure que ça
prend quand vous le rappeler très très
bien dans votre complément de rapports
aujourd'hui
bien monsieur le rapporteur avoue copine
monsieur le président d'abord pour
remercier bien sûr la cour pour son
travail et les différents intervenants
aussi bien là creux que la djs pc et edf
bon je vais me tourner avec pondre à
poser une question de df tout simplement
puisque je crois qu'il ya encore une
partie d'intervention qui est prévu pour
leur nom tout simple question vous
d'accord edf vous nous dites on
souhaiterait qu'il n'y ait pas un
déficit aussi important entre ce que
nous avançons pour payer les producteurs
est ce que nous recevons par la csbe et
cela montre je crois pas milliards 8 et
me dit on souhaiterait bien sûr être
remboursés de cette somme et vous posez
ensuite de dire même s'il ya des coûts
financiers du ce manque et nous
souhaiterions également être remboursé
de ses coûts financiers
jusque là on vous comprend et c'était le
premier point de votre intervention est
ensuite vous avez amené à deuxième point
que j'ai mis du temps à comprendre et je
suis même pas sûr de bien l'avoir
compris vous dites un ça pose problème
la csp pour le coup des ménages bien et
plutôt que de dd les énergies
renouvelables j'ai cru comprendre mais
j'espère avoir mal compris
il faudrait mieux aider edf dans ses
investissements
c'est à dire que vous portez un jugement
de dire eh bien pour diminuer ce coût
pour la facture des ménages est bien
arrêtons la politique de soutien aux
énergies renouvelables
ah oui j'ai bien j'ai bien mal compris
alors vous allez pas me fait pas dire ça
j'ai cru j'ai cru comprendre ça ou alors
faudra qu'on m'explique quel est ce
deuxième point et vous avez dit là c'est
le coup de la csp
il vaut très cher à cause des énergies
renouvelables ne comprendre quand même
et vous élisent si on aidait davantage
des investissements traditionnels d'edf
eh bien ça serait bien beaucoup mieux
arrêtez moi de vous dire mon désaccord
est en tout cas si j'ai mal compris
merci de clarifier il ya monsieur
piquemal vous avez vraiment bravo
défendre moi j'ai bien compris que vous
supportiez l'impopularité que représente
la charge de la cspe qui s'additionne à
la facture que penn n'importe quel
consommateur français est dans cette
facture il y à tous il ya des tris citer
que vous produisez et que vous vendez et
puis effectivement les investissements
que vous devez faire ayant plus cspe
c'est comme ça que moi je l' ai compris
allez-y merci monsieur le président rené
possibilité effectivement de clarifier
mon propos et je vais essayer
d'effectivement de jeu de deux éléments
de réponse
le premier c'est que naturellement le
développement des énergies renouvelables
se trouve au coeur de la stratégie d'edf
nous l'avons démontré en 2011 en
intégrant la totalité de df énergies
nouvelles dans la stratégie industrielle
du groupe
nous l'avons montré nous montrons tous
les ans puisque le développement de
nouvelles capacités dans le domaine et
renouvelables occupent 1,2 milliard
d'euros c'est à dire que c'est la
catégorie des investissements nouvelles
capacités qui est la plus importante
pour le groupe edf et donc le
développement des énergies renouvelables
sont au coeur de la stratégie d'edf et
donc mon propos n'était certainement pas
du tout lié à la politique au mix
énergétique la politique énergétique
décidé ainsi qu'à la stratégie de
développement du groupe non il était
plutôt de dire que si je pourrais très
concret si je prends la facture d'un
d'un client d'un de nos consommateurs au
tarif bleu
comme nous nous payons en moyenne 135
euros du mégawattheure par an dans cette
danse et 135 euros du mégawattheure par
an il y à 42 taxe dès que la cspe sera
passé à 10 et la part du tarif qui nous
permet d'investir que ce soit dans les
réseaux que ce soit dans la maintenance
et bien c'est le solde est donc mon
propos était simplement de dire dans les
réseaux dans la maintenance dans le
développement de nouvelles capacités de
renouvelables mon propos était
simplement de dire que si ce 135 euros
du mégawattheure par an peut augmenter
ça c'est le gouvernement qui décide et
bien c'est que cette hausse des 135
euros
si elle va dans les taxes elle ne nous
permet pas à nous de financer
l'augmentation de nos investissements
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
devons chez edf d'être une force de
proposition pour étaler l'augmentation
de cette taxe sur une plus longue
période pour permettre au contraire le
développement de désinvestissements du
groupe ou d'autres sources
mais ce que j'ai même l'important c'est
une comprennent même si je suis beaucoup
plus longue
mes collègues tout le monde l'important
c'est que je comprenne monsieur le
directeur financier de l'edf vous ne
dites la csp ne nous permet pas
d'investir pourtant qu'un vous en
bénéficier puisque vous avez été les
bénéficiaires de trois appels d'offres
je crois récemment un tout comme l'a dit
la cour des comptes assez élevé on
n'avait pas qui était l'éolien offshore
on vous en avait bénéficié de la d
investissement par lasser espère donc
vous la cspe permet malgré tout que vous
réalisiez des investissements et comme
d'autres producteurs d'électricité donc
là je peux pas entendre de dire que vous
n'y a pas d'investissement à cause des
taxes et en particulier espèrent qu est
ce que vous voulez dire exactement quand
on se comprenne bien pourquoi la cs peur
ne permet pas les investissements là
prévient de vous démontrer le contraire
au moins partiellement
et peut-être qu'il y aura des
compléments de la cour et qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire exactement
je n'arrive toujours pas à comprendre en
fait c'est l'augmentation de la csbe qui
prend la capte d'armes pardon monsieur
le président ces jeux c'est une
augmentation de la cspe qui prend cette
capacité la capacité donc d'augmentation
des investissements cessé de la facture
du consommateur non mon propos est pas
du tout de remettre en cause la masse
des investissements à faire dans le
temps les énergies renouvelables qui
explique la hausse
justement de ces charges de 2 milliards
à 9 ou 11 milliards d'ici 2020
c'est pas du tout mon propos mais c'est
de dire que la hausse de cette taxe est
trop significatif sur la facture du
consommateur et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous pensons que élargir
pour le dire est que élargir l'assiette
de cette taxe à d'autres formes
d'énergie permettrait d'en limiter la
hausse et arrive vous dites qu'il ya un
effort trop important pour l'énergie
renouvelable par rapport à ce que vous
souhaiteriez qui est serait le nucléaire
voilà c'est pour l'ailier clair monsieur
là vous êtes dans un débat
vous avez toute notion à porter il vous
aurez se voir remettre aux conclusions
d'un autre rapport oui mais je voudrais
que monsieur je voudrais pas qu'il y ait
d'ambiguïté à la sortie de cet entretien
vous faites une première remarque sur
l'écart financier ce que côté des je
comprends très bien
le deuxième point soit vous nous dites
le mécanisme csbf nous permet pas
d'investir dans les énergies
renouvelables et à ce mois on peut
l'entendre vous nous expliquer pourquoi
mais vous pouvez pas d'une façon
imprécise et floue dire ben oui il ya un
investissement important dans la cspe
certes et vous en profiter dans les
investissements comme je viens de le
dire c'est un investissement pour les
énergies renouvelables et vous dit et
cela nous permet pas nouer edf
d'investir ailleurs donc le investir
ailleurs si ce n'est pas les énergies
renouvelables c'est donc soit à partir
du pétrole ou du gaz
je ne crois pas que ce soit votre
souhait et mais au moins que ça soit
affirmée vous dit à ce moment là je peux
longtemps monsieur le président mais que
ça soit 10 ou moins clairement devant
cette commission
si vous trouvez que ses propres
importants
l'investissement pour les renouvelables
c'est que vous avez d'autres
investissements à faire et en
particulier dans le nucléaire et que ça
soit dit comme ça et les réseaux et les
réseaux mais là ne dépasse bon là que
les investissements du renouvelable se
trouve important ne naît pas reposer
pour le port vieux puma une dernière
fois parce que moi je vous ai très bien
compris mais vous avez le droit
une dernière fois de lui répondre et le
rapporteur fera de votre réponse ce
qu'il faudra dans son rapport allez-y
merci mon premier point de clarification
je n'ai jamais dit penser
écrit nulle part que les investissements
dans les énergies renouvelables était
trop important pas du tout d'ailleurs
c'est au coeur de la stratégie d'edf
et c'est là le développement de
capacités le plus important que volvo
peut en revanche en revanche financer le
développement uniquement par
l'augmentation de cette taxe qui portent
uniquement sur l'électricité nous semble
créer un déséquilibre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes très
favorables à l'idée qui a été émise dans
le rapport de la cour des comptes qui
est d'élargir l'assiette de la
perception de cette compensation à
d'autres formes donné d'énergie que ce
ne soient pas simplement le consommateur
d'électricité qui paie là ce
développement et qui subissent la hausse
de cette taxe c'était mon seul propos
certainement pas de remettre en cause ou
de dire que nous investissons trop dans
le domaine des énergies renouvelables
c'est un axe stratégique majeur du
groupe dire merci j'interviens la
demande et la parole jean claude lenoir
aussi mais vous vous inscrivez les uns
les autres
enfin moi je me réjouis quand même en
tant que président du groupe de
l'énergie donc parlementaires français
suivant le problème que gdf ne soit plus
simplement un horrible producteurs de
nucléaire mais investissent fortement
également dans les énergies
renouvelables et que vous y ait remporté
2 23 deux secteurs dans le loft shore
éolien même si je trouve le prix de
cette fraîcheur un peu élevé alors
jean-pierre d'abord même si maintenant
merci mais ma question mon observation
ne s'adresse pas aidé f
j'ai bien compris que en tout cas ce que
j'ai compris moi de l'intervention du
directeur financier c'est que et df
considère qu'il n'a pas être le banquier
de la cspe premier point et deuxièmement
que la perception et la mise en oeuvre
des énergies renouvelables avait un coût
en qualité d'opérateur et qui demandait
que soit pris en compte donc
effectivement je n'ai pas d'observations
et de questions aux élèves
en revanche en ce qui concerne
effectivement la cour la cruella dgec
vous avez effectivement dans vos
rapports
avancer cette idée que la csp aurait pu
être portés différemment et notamment
envisager une fiscalité différente ou
d'autres contributeurs une question que
vous n'avez pas abordé et donc je la
pose pour le cas où vous elle vous aurez
à interpeller sans que vous vous
exprimiez nous avons nous voyons bien
aujourd'hui que l'apport important on
peut dire massif pour les uns moins
important pour les autres des énergies
renouvelables a déjà un impact sur le
prix de l'énergie puisque a été évoqué
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs le cac nous
avions à certains moments un prix
négatif puisque de toute évidence on
voit bien qu'au niveau des marchés à
partir de là on a un apport massif
l'effet direct que ça un manque ablement
sur le modèle économique de l'énergie et
des perspectives à 2015 2020 et au delà
on voit bien que l'évolution du prix de
l'énergie et donc l'impact des énergies
renouvelables va être un élément
important mais sur ce volet très général
je prendrai un exemple un pappalardo
sera pas étonné que je prenne celui du
photovoltaïque puisqu'il est dit tout à
l'heure
qu'effectivement nous étions très au
dessus de ce qui était envisagé et que
dans les perspectives 2020 nous étions
très au dessus de ce qui était souhaité
mais si on en reste à une approche
globale pour ne prendre que cette
énergie
je ne suis pas sûr que nous approchions
très précisément les coûts si je prends
le rapport charpin dans ses orientations
en décembre 2010 dans le rapport charpin
tout le monde considérait et la
commission premier qu' il y à un domaine
qui ne devrait pas être affectée par le
moratoire c'était domaine des
particuliers est d'ailleurs celui ci
aujourd'hui il reste en dehors des
appels d'offres
sauf que le prix est fixé
trimestriellement ce qui n'est pas sans
poser des difficultés d'un marché qui et
je dirai quand même un certain
or il est aujourd'hui un de ceux qui a
été le plus impacté par le moratoire
avec des effets sur le plan économique
important alors que sur le solaire
photovoltaïque
on a en fait deux économies la grosse
économie des fermes avec la nécessité de
raccordement réseau du renforcement des
réseaux et des prairies à sa pose et le
particulier qui est dans la file depuis
un petit peu de l'otan consommation à
l'allemande si je puis dire
donc je je j'évoque ce cas pour dire
est-ce que effectivement dans la proche
des énergies renouvelables et de la cspe
il ne faudrait pas peut-être que l'on
puisse aller plus loin dans l'étude des
énergies parce qu'il peut y avoir d
impact non négligeable en termes de
coûts notamment par référence à
l'implication sur les réseaux et on sait
que les réseaux est un aspect non
négligeable
demain dans le prix je ne suis pas sûr
que je le sache répondre avec précision
avec cette question qui interpelle à la
fois sur plusieurs sujets comment dire
un certain les hypothèses de prix rester
rappelé tout à l'heure quand on fait
l'exercice qui consiste à regarder les
prévisions de prix qui était fait pour
différentes énergies pas seulement pour
l'électricité
il ya trois ans 5 ans 10 ans et cetera
qu'on s'amuse à les mettre sur le même
tableau sert général assez démoralisant
pour les prévisionnistes deuxièmement
l'impact de d'énergie diffuse de
production énergie diffuse sur les
réseaux je ne sais pas où on et edf et
je pensais autant rte et erdf qui sont
concernés deux pour mesurer ce que ça
représente en termes d'investissements
pour adapter notre réseau à une forme
différente de production d'électricité
sera un coup de ça c'est clair
mais comme tout changement je dirais par
définition que le jour on a fait les
centrales nucléaires ça modifier le
réseau par rapport à ce qu'il était
avant
je ne suis pas capable aujourd'hui pour
ma part de dire qu'elle peut être naître
pacte michel tu peux nous ne sommes pas
capables je suis pas sûr que quelqu'un
en soit vraiment capable
il faut travailler sur le fond sur sur
les conséquences que ça réellement sur
le réseau et est aussi faire la part
entre ce qui est maintenance du réseau
évolutions du réseau
bien sûr il ya aussi des travaux de
maintenance et ensuite ce qu'il faut le
l'affecté entre guillemets parce que ce
que vous dites à tel ou tel type de
d'énergie ou non il ya une chose de
clair un peu comme le disait les
recteurs financer ddf il ya des dépenses
à faire c'est aussi ce qu'on disait dans
le rapport sur le nucléaire
on a des dépenses importantes à faire et
il faut probablement vers des sujets
globalement doux aussi notre réflexion
sur est-ce qu'il faut que certaines
dépenses soit uniquement porté par le
consommateur d'électricité ou élargies
parce que c'est une vision globale
d'aidé des coûts et de la production
qu'il faut avoir avant d'essayer de
régler finement chacune des chaînes
chacun des types finalement de dépenses
qui sont affectés sur le photovoltaïque
on voit avec intérêt les conséquences
des dispositions qui ont été prises bien
sûr il faut évaluer tout ça pour savoir
si on y soit bonne voie ou si on peut
faire quelque chose de plus efficaces ou
de plus efficient mais dans une vision
mon sens dans une vision globale de
l'évolution du système électrique et
l'objectif qu'on ne cherche à atteindre
à court moyen et long terme
oui c'est plutôt un échange entre les
membres de la commission que j'ouvre
très brièvement je vous rassure je
comprends que les travaux de la
commission touchent à leur fin et que
les uns les autres sont avec un stylo
pour commencer à rédiger les
observations voir les conclusions qui
seront proposés mon avis à moi c'est que
les objectifs qui étaient recherchés par
les auteurs de la proposition ayant
conduit à cette commission d enquête
n'ayant pas été complètement atteint
loin s'en faut
on cherche à ouvrir un débat propos la
cspe sur le nucléaire pour finalement
mettre en cause la part du nucléaire en
france
moi je suis en désaccord avec en tout
cas la perception qui est retenu des
propos tenus par monsieur piquemal
jeunes en désaccord dombes et je jeu le
jeu je le je le dis ici un point
d'histoire
la cspo a été créée par la loi du 10
février 2000 s'est ouvert les marchés
loi qui était proposée par le
gouvernement de l'époque
à l'époque le renouvelable et est
balbutiant et donc le coût qui impacte
et la facture et des crudités et est
appréciée comme relativement modeste
c'est le développement du renouvelable
avec notamment le grenelle de
l'environnement et des initiatives
prises par les anciens gouvernements qui
ont succédé à partir de 2002 qui a créé
cette jennir cette bulle une mauvaise
connotation en tout cas cette montée
très très forte
et donc aujourd'hui nous devons nous
parlementaires assumer cette
responsabilité
c'est bien parce que nous avons voulu à
nice et et du gouvernement
développer le renouvelable que le
problème se pose je voudrais cet égard
dans des précisions que vous pourrez pas
à porter sans doute dès à présent c'est
quelle est la part du surcoût lié aux
renouvelables
affecté au réseau parce que quand on
parle du renouvelable
on ne parle que de la production mais la
production de renouvelables a un impact
considérable sur les réseaux donc
j'aimerais que vous puissiez être amené
à donner ce chiffre âme deuxièmement
autre question que vous ne pourrez sans
doute pas me donner dès à présent mais
je posais la question parce que vous rem
rappelé que le budget d'edf est
constitué de recettes et de dépenses et
que les recettes sont pour partie fixés
par les pouvoirs publics par le
gouvernement
c'est la différence entre les tarifs et
les prix du marché
alors dans les recettes si on prend le
chiffre 100 quelle est la part qui
résulte des tarifs et donc de ressources
décidées par les pouvoirs publics et la
part qui relève tout simplement des
marchés négociés dubreu mans en france
ou à l'étranger parce que je comprends
lorsque vous disiez un problème qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer c'est que fonds
ont un impact au niveau gouvernemental à
la fois dans le budget du df les
dépenses ce sont les dépenses liées à la
cspe comme on le dit
et puis et puis et puis et puis les
recettes donc il faut bien trouver une
solution pour être cohérent par rapport
aux différentes interventions
il est important effectivement je suis
d'accord avec vous que vous puissiez
nous dit réellement mais comme je crois
que c'est très difficile
quelle est la part d'investissement clés
nécessaires pour l'heure pour adapter le
réseau aux nouvelles formes de
production du renouvelable
pour le moment j'ai entendu edf ou rte
et erdf dire ça un impact important mais
on n'arrive pas à savoir si c'est un
impact important dans ce sens que
il peut se faire dans l'actualisation
normale dans la rénovation nombre de
réseaux aussi c'est un an un impact
particulièrement important au niveau
supplémentaires ou complémentaires
on n'a jamais eu le détail donc vous
pouvez encore nous dire aujourd'hui donc
pour vous aller dans ce sens que c'est
important mais ce serait bien qu'on
puisse le l'évaluer réellement quel est
le coût en le différenciant comme ça
peut être fait sur l'actualisation des
mesures post fukushima
pauvre venez pour finir pour relativiser
le propos de mon collègue j'ai entendu à
la fin de votre intervention monsieur
directeur financier l'explication de
votre deuxième point vous avez dit la
cspe est importante mais je vous le
signale pas ce que je souhaiterais que
effectivement la taxation se fasse pas
simplement auprès des consommateurs
d'électricité auprès des consommateurs
de toute l'énergie en général c'est ce
que je n'avais pas entendu
merci de l'avoir précisiez à la fin de
votre intervention
c'est si c'était ça votre deuxième point
il est beaucoup plus compréhensible
puisqu'il ya des amendements à la
question réseau de jean pull noir
moi je vous rappelle que de par la loi
cette erdf qui attend charge le prix de
tous les coûts de raccordement de toutes
les énergies nouvelles s'il y a non
seulement la partie raccordement des
renforcements faire sur un réseau sur 2
km 3 km c'est à la charge de erdf
c'est un message que j'adresse à edf
pour sa filiale
il serait inadmissible dans cet extrait
il est inadmissible qu'en ce moment
votre filiale tente parfois de faire
porter ses prix de renforcement
nécessaire à des collectivités
territoriales avec ville où des
syndicats d'électricité
j'en profite au passage répondez à la
question jean claude lenoir amendé par
genou rapporte bien bien sûr présents
monsieur
c'est scandaleux
allez-y malheureusement j'étais venu
aujourd'hui pour parler de la de la cspe
du déséquilibre de la cspe est pas du
tout des énergies renouvelables pas du
tout du coût des énergies renouvelables
pas du tout des investissements dans les
énergies renouvelables et donc
malheureusement je ne pourrai pas vous
donner les chiffres précis comme je
souhaiterais le faire si vous me
permettrez nous reviendrons vers vous je
pourrais simplement faire un commentaire
qui est de dire que certes il ya un coût
induit tivement naturellement on le voit
bien mais que ce coût est couvert par
les investissements faits par rte et
erdf et donc couverts par la
réglementation et le turpe et donc la
partie dans le tarif intégré tout alors
je parlais de 135 euros du
mégawattheures la facture moyenne ttc là
dedans il y en a environ je dirais 50
pour rte plus de erdf
voilà et donc c est donc ces coûts sont
déjà pris en compte par une
réglementation spécifique et donc par
nous entrons souvent faveur des fr2
entre dans la discussion autour de tueur
no 4 la quatrième personne de la
quatrième période de réglementation et
tout ceci est couvert par ce mécanisme
mais si vous me permettez j'en suis
vraiment désolé je reviendrai vers vous
avec un chiffre précis c'est la moindre
des choses
deuxième question vous poser c'est la
part du tarif dans les recettes d'edf en
france alors il y à bien deux
composantes de nos recettes qui sont
fixées par
le tarif ou enfin plutôt parcelles une
réglementation il ya d'une part le tarif
intégré de vente et d'autre part le prix
de l'arenh donc là à l'issue dé la la
réforme la loi nome la réforme du marché
français
comme vous le savez nous devons rendre
jusqu'à 25 % de notre production
d'origine nucléaire à un prix qui est
déterminé par les pouvoirs publics il
est aujourd'hui les 40 2 euros du
mégawattheure il s'agit là de la part
uniquement énergie fourniture d'énergie
et donc si on fait la somme de la part
des tarifs pendant ce que nous vendons
tarif qui est environ 80% des recettes
du groupe et de ce que nous vendons à
l'arrêt nous arrivons à au dessus de 90
% des recettes d'edf en france qui sont
fixés justement pavois par le
gouvernement ou par voie réglementaire
c'était c'était de danse c'était dedans
oui absolument parce que quand je
raisonne un nom c'est un tarif intégré
c'est à dire que si je reprends mon 135
euros du mégawattheures j'en avais 42
taxe voilà c'est plus 90% tout compris
le nord voilà en france
votre liberté des pâtres et non elle est
bien de regarder c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous devons d'être une
force de proposition et pour pour
pourrait identifier des solutions
techniques qui sont en la matière
d'origine financière permettant d'étaler
un certain nombre de déséquilibres et
donc de créer des marges de manoeuvre
pour les plus voir public s'ils le
souhaitent sur la facture des
consommateurs
moi je voudrais poser une question d'âge
des comptes dans vos pistes de réflexion
il y en a une qui marque y avait ma
curiosité mais j'aimerais besoin d'une
explication vous suggérez parmi les
pistes et pourquoi pas faire supporter
la gestion de tout ce mécanisme non pas
aux producteurs d'électricité mais aux
transporteurs
qu'est ce que kelly des aviez-vous
derrière avantages inconvénients
je précise sont des pistes de réflexion
c'est pas des propositions et notamment
sur cette partie là sont les pistes de
près de réflexion qui sont pas du tout
propre ou qu'on n'a pas inventé une
autre côté vous les retrouvez dans l'
annexe mieux préciser que dans le texte
c'est notamment des réflexions qui se
font du côté des ministères des finances
et des directions du trésor qui a une
réflexion sur la transparence du marché
sur effectivement le rôle qu'ont fait
jouer à aider f
avec ce dispositif de delà de la cspe
par rapport à la vision qu'ils ont d'une
ouverture plus plus large plus normal on
va dire du marché avec des rôles qui
pourrait être identique de tous les
producteurs pas uniquement du producteur
historique d'où cette idée de dire si on
faisait porter le dispositif de la cspe
pas par le producteur mais par le
transporteur aide en a qu'un on
reviendrait à une logique ou moins
théoriques en tout cas sur le papier qui
seraient plus grandes comme je le dédie
nous n'avons pas été plus loin dans dans
cette réflexion mais on l'est dont la
nuit parce qu'effectivement ça nous a
dit il ya sous l'angle théorique quelque
chose d'intéressant à regarder après ça
vaut la peine d'en discuter au fond par
exemple j'en ai absolument pas discuter
avec les df n'est ni même avec la dgec
ou avec la creuse simplement pour dire
que c'est quand même des sujets qu'ils
sont
visiblement en cours de réflexion et qui
vaudra la peine de regarder
ah mais ça empêche c voilà là clairement
on n'est pas sur un sujet sur cette
partie des qualités transparence on
n'est pas sur un sujet immédiatement
financier avec une conséquence
financière
je pense que pour ceux qui portent ce
genre de réflexion il ya l'idée qu'en
n'augmentant la liquidité et la
transparence quelque part on a aussi des
conséquences sur le coût du dispositif
mais alors je n'ai vu aucun chiffrage de
de ce point et je n'ai absolument pas
approfondi un petit peu l'assiette pas
aussi loin que d'autres pistes de
réflexion que vous nous suggériez oui
c'est pour ça il ya vraiment de tout
tous les niveaux possibles
d'augmentation de monsieur le rapporteur
en place les producteurs à égalité c'est
surtout ça fondamentalement donc on
élargit un peu sachant comme y en a un
qui est un producteur qui a l'essentiel
du marché est plus grande part ça change
un peu mais pas aussi radicalement la
situation que ça pourrait l'être
sachant dans tous les cas ça ne change
pas le fait qu'à la fin à quelqu'un qui
paye mais la question a été posée et je
compte on la pose dans le rapport c'est
à dire que est-ce que l'obligation
d'achat c'est simplement edf ou c'est
l'ensemble
des producteurs qui ont l'obligation
d'achat et vous trouver une formule
simplifiée pour dire cela c'est à dire
que ça peut être le transporteur unique
rte est donc ça évite ce problème entre
producteurs j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était cela que vous vouliez esprits
mais oui si on revient à une notion
enfin je vous pouvez préciser madame
pappalardo si je reviens la notion
exprimé dans le deuxième point que j'ai
du mal que j'ai eu du mal à comprendre
qui était que la cspe ne doit pas être
simplement payé par les consommateurs
d'électricité
j'ai cru comprendre cela après beaucoup
de temps et c'est un point important
parce que ça c'est un changement même de
de nature même et j'aurais aimé avoir
sur ce point l'avis de la cre e et de la
dg c'est peut-être eu une précision 3
pour les membres de la commission
c'est que la cspe en fait toute personne
qui consomme électricité quel que soit
le fournisseur psp l'idée de transférer
sur le turpe néanmoins intéressante
parce que il y a des consommateurs
notamment industriels qui bénéficient
d'exonérations auquel cas je pense que
c'est à ça que vous faisiez référence
auquel cas même ses consommateurs gros
consommateur perd également la csbe
non il ya en a deux sujets sur leur demi
de transparence sur l'épisode réflexion
il y à un élément de réflexion à
regarder sur les règles d'exonération
actuelle qu'on a signalé parce que
compte tenu de l'augmentation de la csbe
il faut être conscient que les
exonérations augmente aussi puisque plus
vous augmentez le la cspe plus forcément
ce que vous exonérer augmente aussi
et si vous doublez la contribution
unitaire bas vous doublez les
exonérations avec ce que disait madame
peavey c'est que une partie des
exonérations ont été mises sur les
entreprises industrielles mais nous
rappelions que ce n'était pas uniquement
les entreprises industrielles sncf aussi
par exemple bénéficient de ces
exonérations
donc ça c'est un premier élément de
réflexion qu'il ya plein de deux des
deux ramifications complexes et le
deuxième sujet c'est celui qui est plus
en bas sur cette idée de dire mettons
les producteurs à égalité donc ne
faisons pas porter de l'équilibré du
système sur le producteur et df
historique mais sur un autre ça pas de
lien avec les exonérations rien
n'empêcherait de laisser bien sûr des
exonérations ou de les doubler ou lille
supprimer ça pas de lien voilà oui mais
je crains que je ne puisse pas me
prononcer forte de la creuse sur
l'élargissement de l'assiette de la cspe
par contre si tu mens si un groupe de
travail sur ce sujet la croix
participera mais là je ne préfère pas
oui pardon monsieur le sénateur sur la
sueur sur l'élargissement je ne peux
finalement que que que redire ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que la question est la
question est compliquée parce qu'on a
une charge qui qui augmente et donc qui
pèsent sur les consommateurs
d'électricité donc l'idée de la répartir
sur une assiette un peu plus large est
assez assez assez naturel en même temps
les prix des autres énergies sont eux
aussi très élevé et rien ne garantit
qu'ils augmenteront moins vite que les
prix de l'électricité
j'avais donné et puis du point de vue de
la maîtrise des coûts on peut se dire
que le fait que l'ensemble des coûts
liés à la production d'électricité soit
visible sur la facture du sur la facture
du consommateur d'électricité procède
plutôt d'une losique d'une logique
vertueuse donc c'est c'est un élément de
réflexion mais je ne peux que dire ça à
ce stade le rapporteur si demain une
réflexion sur ce sujet moi je suis sûr
que la dg ex fera partie de ceux qui
auront beaucoup d'idées de suggestions
mais taxée de ma le consommateur de
fioul le consommateur de gaz aux
consommateurs de bio carburants
c'est un problème politique c'est pas
pas seulement technique alors la
réflexion tout le monde pourra
participer à ce débat
la décision ne sera pas facile mes chers
collègues d'autres questions non
d'écouter un grand merci à la merci à
vous vraiment merci pour le travail
fourni et je tiens à dire on du
rapporteur en mon nom au long de du du
sénat
comme l'ont rappelé différents
intervenants merci à vous et la creuse
et l'a déjà écrit des airs pour voir
participe à ce débat
je pense que vous verrez des éléments de
ceux de vos conclusions dans votre
rapport et de ce débat je pense que
notre rapporteur il réservera une place
importante dans son rapport merci
beaucoup à vous
je veux remercier aussi l'ensemble des
participants merci beaucoup
la cour des comptes à la fois pour son
premier rapport qu'a lancée en partie
cette commission denquête et ce rapport
complémentaire dans la des délais très
réduits mais vous avez fait face donc
merci beaucoup merci à l'autre de se
dépasser de nouvelle fois parce qu'on
s'est vu ma mère à plusieurs reprises et
merci aussi à des essais merci edf qui
s'est aussi déplacée plusieurs fois pour
over d'un des auditions le rapport
touche à sa fin qu'on ai dis donc
nous essaierons de tenir les délais qui
est le 7 juillet effectivement on a une
part importante dans ce rapport sera sur
la csp et peut-être les restaurants
s'il ya des pistes mais encore beaucoup
d'interrogations par rapport au système
mettre en place comme vous nous l'avez
signalé aujourd'hui
merci voilà pour les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur le coût réel
de l'électricité si vous souhaitez
revoir cette audition elle est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très belle
journée à tous